c'est non non
je viens de recevoir la lettre
circulaire suivante
monsieur mon désir est de réunir dans un
même livre des individualités française
homme de télévision et médias artistes
de cinéma de théâtre musiciens
classiques écrivains hommes d'affaires
artistes de variétés grands chefs
culinaires le sujet du livre concernera
avec un s vos attirance et relation avec
le vin est votre avis sur l'acte de
boire je serai sans sd plus flatté s'en
est si vous acceptiez de paraître en ce
livre approuvé par les éditions hachette
avec deux t quand même
je vous serai 100 et ce très
reconnaissant de me contacter par
téléphone de zen pour établir les
modalités et es nécessaires en vue d'un
entretien avec toute ma sympathie et
l'espoir de votre future collaboration
je vous prie de croire monsieur en mes
sentiments les meilleurs voilà c'est un
monsieur pierre sokolov qui m'écrit seul
litre est connu j'aime beaucoup votre
lettre monsieur sokolov je ne m'étendrai
pas sur la platitude du texte ni sur
l'indigence orthographique dont il est
parsemé après tout si les illettrés
n'avait pas voix au chapitre rika zaraï
serait obligé de chanter pour gagner sa
vie
au risque de déclencher une nouvelle
poussée d'antisémitisme jusque chez les
juifs
j'aime beaucoup votre lettre monsieur
sokolov parce qu'elle vient de me donner
une idée si j'ai bien compris votre
démarche vous entendez faire écrire
votre livre à l'oeil par une bande de
[ __ ] gratuits dont vous compter sur la
verve ou le talent pour pallier votre
propre incompétence littéraire en
échange de quoi vous toucherez les
droits d'auteur à leur place c'est
normal puisque c'est vous qui avez la
machine à écrire
c'est vraiment une bonne idée
des lettres comme la vôtre monsieur
sokolov pour vous donner le fond de ma
pensée est tapissé celui de ma poubelle
ils m'ont échoue à quatre ou cinq par
mois connement n'y a pas d'autre mot je
n'y réponds jamais certes vous n'aurez
pas un mot de moi monsieur ce que l'ofs
dans votre prochain ouvrage parce que
plus le temps passe et me presse avant
que mort s'ensuive plus j'ai tendance à
écrire pour nourrir ma famille et moi
j'ai envie d'arroser la vôtre mais du
mepi louis mais des vendeurs
quelle excellente idée vous eûtes
monsieur sokolov figurez vous que je les
reprises à mon compte tenez vous bien
tenez vous mieux permettez moi de vous
faire lecture d'une lettre que je
viendrais disait
pierre desproges chroniqueur haineux à
monsieur untel artisans compagnons de
france monsieur mon désir est de réunir
dans une même bâtisse les individualités
artisanale française maçon peintre
plombier carreleur électricien et c'est
le genre de la maison sera luxueux mais
sobre et de bon goût et rappellera à
tous votre savoir faire je serai des
plus flatté si vous acceptiez de meules
à construire à l'oeil
je vous serais très reconnaissant de me
contacter par téléphone pour décider de
la date de début des travaux avec toute
ma sympathie et l'espoir de votre
collaboration et sa pire des proches
allons bonsoir monsieur ce golf et
encore merci je ne m'attarde pas j'ai du
courrier en retard
madame après avoir baisé en
collaboration avec madame mercier
l'épicière mon désir est de réunir dans
un même lit des individualités s'auto
pas française je serai très flatté si
vous acceptiez de coucher avec moi pour
pas un rond etc
je
fais peu non
[Musique]